So we are lucky enough to be here this morning to interview Charlie White and it's May 18,
2011.
It's too late.
Thank you so much for agreeing to do this.
I want to start off by just asking you to tell us your earliest recollections, where
you're born, what year, and where you grew up.
I was born and Detroit Michigan in April 2014.
I was the youngest of nine children, four brothers and four sisters all over the
first.
There two of us left myself and brother next to me.
They were typical, we were poor, but I normally said that, it's not really, no, we were poor
because I never starved.
I always said food.
I always said a roof over my head and went to clothes and the whole thing.
And the old saying was, cardboard and shoe, we had a few, sure, sure.
But I was just a typical childhood in those days.
What kind of things do you remember doing as a child playing games?
I remember playing sports.
My brother, he played basketball and he played in high school.
He didn't go to college, but he played high school.
I used to watch his games and we'd hit the playgrounds on the weekends.
We'd sat at the morning and had to break a dog.
We were out in the alleys and on the playgrounds playing basketball.
It was more like a religion, we played all kinds of sports.
And contrary to popular belief, there was pretty good hockey players in my neighborhood.
Being wintertime, we played hockey and we played tennis and all that, but basketball just
became the sport.
Basketball and football, it's a good baseball player.
The basketball became the game of a choice, a not-played YMCA,
a Jewish community center.
But also one thing I did when I was 10 years old, 19 years old, I used to swim for the YMCA.
And I wasn't too bad, but he transferred closer to a place near my home and everybody left the YMCA.
The coach left and everybody followed him.
We used to swim against the girls' town teams from the country clubs and all that, and we did pretty good.
So swimming was big to me for about three or four years, from about nine to about 13.
I'm still playing basketball, but I did, somewhere, I just swimming and then evening at big clubs.
Sure, sure.
But that's basically what we do.
What do you recall growing up in Detroit around the racialization of Detroit was there.
You said you swam against the kids in the country club, did you sort of have any kind of feeling towards you guys?
Well, they did, but nothing was said.
I mean, they just felt, they had that superior feeling that they were better because they had to have much better facilities.
We were at decent facilities, but they had the country clubs and the whole thing.
That feeling was there and it was always there that we wanted to win.
Detroit was a, I love Detroit, but it was polarized.
I mean, most of the blacks lived in about three or four different areas and their ties, their tiered, Jewish people lived there,
and the Polish people lived on a little place called Amdrami.
Sure.
And great athletes came up Amdrami.
And that was like Dindy high schools in Amdrami.
So we played against each other and throughout the city.
But it was mostly, there was only one that I can remember, one school at that time that had mixed athletic teams.
And that was cast tech, which was one of the top schools in the city.
Roughly what year were we talking about in the mid-50s?
So your high school, as I'm here, you say, was not this aggregate?
No, well I went to cast tech.
To begin with, but I didn't stay there, I ended up back in my neighbor's school.
But yeah, the neighbor's school that I played the most basketball in was not segregated.
The cast tech was and they always said pretty good teams.
But you know, it was pretty much it.
I did a lot of hard jobs growing up as a kid to generate income.
I learned this from all my brothers and sisters who all worked and went to school and did all the things.
They all graduated from high school and none went to college.
I was the only one.
But I worked for cutting lawns, washing windows, whatever.
And then I got a job with large grocery chain, crocus.
And I started working in the meat department just kind of cleaning up and everything.
And then I ended up getting a permanent job as a stock boy and doing okay.
And the job was rough in the neighborhood.
I mean, you had to kind of establish yourself, but I decided in 1958 that I didn't see enough.
And I turned the mind and I decided to see the school see the world and join the military.
And we could have gone in for two years and gone to the Far East.
But I said now let's go in for three and go to Europe.
I'm sorry, we're going to see a few more places and that's what happened.
Okay.
And you were about 18.
17, 18, 20.
20.
Almost to a 19.
Thank you so much.
So I started and I played a lot of basketball that was there.
In the military.
Yeah, he talked about that.
Well, we came in and I went in into Ford Noth's.
A little bit right outside, a little bit.
And they had a camp team.
And I went out for it, but I didn't want to have been ordered to make that team.
You had to kind of stay in the states and you travel around and I said,
no, I don't want to stay here.
I want to go to Europe.
And I got on the team there and we played, we could be at like 50 game schedules
and then we had to turn them in.
So yeah.
And then I played a lot of games.
enjoyed myself.
You know, we went to went all over Berlin, all over Germany.
Right.
At that time, the military was disagreed.
Oh, yeah.
So you were actually working with white teammates.
But there was several racial issues in the military.
Can you talk about them?
Well, the majority of MPs were military police were white and from the south.
Okay.
And they harassed us consistently.
Whenever we would be out, there was one African guy there named Bobby,
something other.
And he had a club, a very nice popular club.
And we would go down there and you know, once or twice a month,
MPs would come and just kind of raid the club, you know,
pull everybody out and scoot.
Hang coffee, you know.
And our team used to go down there.
But this was a track team at this time.
Okay.
And we had white kids on the track team and they would tell them to go home
but they wouldn't go.
They would stay with us and they would take us, you know, to jail,
to lock up.
But we'd get out the next couple of hours because we'd call our Colonel
and block out Bob.
You know, it was just a harassment.
Sure.
It was just continued.
Yeah.
Sure.
It continued.
What else were some of your experiences in Germany as?
So I mean, what position did you have in the military then?
Because it wasn't just fully accurate, right?
You had a regular job.
Yeah, I was just, I was in the Army infantry what they called it.
But I didn't spend a lot of time.
I spent what they called TDY, which is temporary duty.
And I would play sports.
But I also was on the track team.
Oh, I didn't even know they had to.
Now I jumped and triple jumped and brought jumped, mouse long jumped and whatever.
But yeah, I did that too.
So I did that to pretty much keep from, you know, doing the life of it.
Every day, every day.
Yeah, right, right.
Kids in Pedro, you know, little sorts of things.
Right.
Yeah.
So did someone recognize you in the military as being a potential athlete
or eventually college or how did that keep talking to me now about how that was?
It was really funny.
We were in the gym one day and I was shooting around.
And this kid from Southern California, he's on our team, Jones, Dick Jones.
He came in the gym and he asked me, see what are you going to do?
I was getting close to my time to come back.
Three of his things.
And he said, what are you going to do when you get out of the military?
I said, you know, I really didn't talk much about it.
And he said, you got to go out to California and go to junior college.
And he said, junior college is free.
And then maybe you can get a scholarship to four years school.
And I thought he was joking.
So I threw the ball out and told him to get out of here, you know, chasing him out of the gym.
Well, guess what happened?
Uh-huh.
I did just that.
I got shipped to California from Germany.
Got out of the army, went to junior college, then came with Durgan State.
Oh, okay.
Now, the thing that I noticed when I got here, I started seeing names in the paper
from some of the other junior colleges in Southern California.
Guys, I knew from Detroit.
So there was a lot of young kids kept from Detroit who came out to California and went to junior college.
What was that?
What do you think?
Because we heard some very similar thing from...
No, because he said that a lot of guys from his neighborhood is Washington, ended up in California.
What was maybe going on back then?
Well, for one thing, the junior colleges back there were not free.
Worked free in East Coast.
East Coast, they were free out here.
Okay.
If you were 21, you could establish residency and you didn't have to pay out of state fees.
So you could go to junior college free.
Oh, you know.
And these coaches would help you get a little odd job here in there where you could work.
Uh-huh.
And then you had to go to scholarship to a four-year school.
Interesting.
So a lot of kids, and plus, you know, who wouldn't want to come to California?
Yeah, that's right.
Detroit, you know what I mean?
It's snow, this is high and freezing.
And there's a lot of different things going on.
And you know, the guys were getting in trouble, friends, relatives, you know,
were in that mix, you know, that you see every day.
I mean, when I was about 17, you had to be 18 to go into the pool halls,
but everybody forwards some kind of paper.
And I used to hang around in the pool hall and, you know, see a lot of stuff going on.
Sure.
So you want to get away from that mainly?
Yes, you know, just a...
More future.
Yeah.
And that was, you know, they just got started coming.
Once a couple of guys came, yeah.
A lot of guys started coming.
And like I said, I saw the guys' names down in L.A.
and different places that come to Detroit.
And so I said, yeah, it was the best thing for me to do.
But anyway, that's what I did.
I came to Oregon State and, you know...
Sure.
I'm going to come back down to that.
That's good.
So you're playing in a junior college.
And someone identifies you and says, who was that?
You know, Paul and I were talking about that.
Well, I don't recall who it was.
Okay.
But I think it was a guy that played with Paul.
His name was Doug.
And I don't remember his last name.
I'm not a factor last time.
I think I heard he was in pretty poor health.
But he and Paul played together.
They were good friends.
Sure.
And I think he might have seen me play in some tournament.
He lived in the general area.
And Paul and told him about me.
But one thing that happened, the year before I came,
where Slash's skill came down to recruit me.
In my fight, he came to my house.
And I talked with him.
You know, and I didn't feel good.
Just didn't feel warm and fuzzy, I guess.
And then a couple of other coaches told me some stories about him.
That I probably wouldn't get to play much.
And sitting on the bench and that sort of thing.
And I said, well, that's just not a good sign.
So I just didn't come here.
And then the next year when Paul came down and we sat down and talked,
like I said, I just felt it.
You know, you feel something.
And like I said, when we talked about me graduating,
I told him I need probably more than two years.
He said, well, I can't give you that in writing.
But I promise you that you graduate.
Anything over the two that I need to graduate, I would graduate.
And I felt that.
And then when I came up here, they focused on education right away as opposed to,
you know, just ask about and laid out what I needed to do.
And that's when I started taking classes and got through.
So you come back to your situation with Slash Guild.
At that point, the team was completely not the same.
The team was segregated in a sense.
There was no African-Americans on the team by that point.
But in Southern California, there were actually board teams that were very...
No, sure.
Very mixed.
Sure.
I wonder how, in your opinion, how did he think that he sort of rationalized?
That he wasn't going to allow his team necessarily to have an edge?
Because at that point, I think it was really recognized that having African-American players on your team was really an edge.
Because they run a different game to the game that Norma's actually talking to us about the game that he was forced to play.
And that is a very kind of contri...
Sure.
...control.
Control.
It was a completely different game.
Running plays.
Yeah, yeah.
Picking screens.
We were on a playground and it was...
You just got it done?
Yeah, behind the back.
Yeah.
Good legs or whatever.
You know, we were out of here, open them before it came in the college.
Sure.
You know, I really don't know.
I try to figure this out because every year...
Yeah.
...and so I said some good teams.
Yeah, you went to the battle for it.
But every year, almost every year, for two years, specifically, that just spoke his heart, I know.
Okay.
Be a Russell.
Yeah.
Was at USF.
And they always played in the region, it was on the West Coast.
And the West Coast teams used to beat him every time and all of them always had players of color.
Right.
And I was out to myself.
Yeah.
You know, you know, I don't know.
You know, and you know the thing that they mentioned about the quota thing they had.
Yeah.
You start one at home, two on the road.
But be a Russell, calling the phrase, you say, but five when you're behind.
Yeah.
You know, be a Russell, started that.
Now, but I heard another explanation of that.
You start one at home.
Yeah.
And two on the road because you got to have somebody to roam together.
Oh, interesting.
You see that.
Yeah, that's just what I was told.
You know, you wouldn't, you know, at that time.
Yeah, sure.
Yeah.
And also at that time, in some parts of the country, you can find logic for black players.
So, you know, if you had to go play in some areas, you know, this is how to like the old,
when Jackie Robinson was playing baseball, the team stayed here and he found him a place to stay in the neighborhood at someone's home.
Yeah.
You know, like that.
So, I know some coaches had mentioned that and they were aware of that and some thought of, you know, felt uncomfortable with that.
Right.
But I don't, I just don't know.
I think he might have wanted to pull the trigger, but I don't know.
He just did.
Yeah.
And plus there weren't a lot of kids up here for him to recruit and most of his kids were local, though, and then he'd go back and look.
Now, I think at that time Washington probably had some.
Washington had a African mayor.
He certainly has, yeah.
Yeah.
He's a great thing.
That's why I was wondering when I was doing the research.
Yeah.
It was to see what was, you know, you saw that California clearly had lost, and you saw, you see Adel had a few.
University of Oregon.
They played them all the time and, yeah.
Yeah.
The guy was kind of holding the line and I was compared to Rupp when I was kind of understanding what was going on.
What was this guy trying to do?
But that was the feeling pretty much amongst those, you know, athletes in California and different places that he didn't really want in.
Right.
But I was really.
So, and I guess nobody wanted to be the first with him.
Yeah.
Because there was not that good feeling about the weather map, you know, you could be quite afraid.
And so when Paul Valentin came down, did he ever tell you that, hey, I'm going to be the coach next because I know I'm in line.
No, he was actually the coach when he came down.
Oh, he's actually, you know, already got in the job.
You already got in the job.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
So you and I had read about it in the paper, but I didn't think much of it really didn't.
He called me.
He contacted me.
Sure.
And then he came to talk to me.
Right.
Okay.
So let's now carry the story on.
Just talk about you now arriving on campus.
And what were some of your earliest recollections for you?
You were arriving on campus.
You're seeing the plays.
What was that like?
One thing that was really funny.
There was a female named Charlie White.
Name Charlie White?
Yes.
Okay.
All right.
And they put her in one of the men's dorms.
This.
This side.
It's one of the men's dorms.
And I got to meet her later.
Look at her.
I met her at a party.
Really?
Okay.
Yes.
When I first got here, they had us doing jobs in cottage groves.
Okay.
Logging.
So in the office.
Yeah.
But I came at the beginning of summer.
So I went right into work.
Okay.
Now, cottage grove is down toward Eugene.
I think it's east of Eugene out in the wilderness.
Okay.
So they took me down there.
And I mean, this was not a good situation.
Yeah.
The first day I was there took me in the evening.
And I said, well, you being me in the night.
Yeah.
So the next morning I get up and I come down and everybody's staring.
And then the next day someone told me that it would be good if I didn't come out at night.
Okay.
So I called Paul and said, I'm leaving.
Yeah.
You know, now.
So they sent somebody and got me.
And I moved in Eugene.
There were some guys in Eugene.
There was three or four guys in this apartment.
And it was, it was mixed with a couple of white students and a couple of, and they were athletes.
And they brought me down there.
And I, and every morning, what we would do, we would catch a bus from Eugene to the cottage grove and working.
And they would come back to Eugene.
So, you know, they'll get the job.
Yeah.
But I didn't live in cottage grove.
And they were just staying.
They need to get me out of here now.
Okay.
So I came to Eugene and then I worked at Summer in the Woods, which was good.
We made a lot of money.
I was going to spend a whole lot, but at that time was a lot of money.
And we did have a place to spend this.
So all of a sudden, along we worked, stuck chicken in the bank.
So we got to school started.
We had a little money.
Right.
It was common for us.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
We could work.
First we got to stip it.
Okay.
Yeah, monthly stip.
So then, start the season.
And I can say we had a, we didn't have a very good team.
We were seven, seven in the bank.
But actually it wasn't the pack eight.
Everybody says the pack eight.
It was the AAWU.
It was the athletic association of Western universities.
Okay.
But it was the original eight schools to two in Oregon, two in Washington, two in Southern
County.
It was the pack eight.
You know, the name pack eight became, it came on later.
But anyway, we were seven, seven in confidence.
I think we were 14, 10 overall or something like that.
And, you know, we, you know, we weren't really thinking anything big the next year.
We just wanted to be competitive.
And I had played small floor with the first year here.
But then they put me in guard the next year.
You know, and all the guys, the only new guy that came in really was, that really helped us with Harry.
The only new guy, Harry Garner.
Okay.
Yeah, he's the only new guy, African American who came in.
Oh, and Lloyd Peterson.
Yeah, I'll take that back.
Lloyd Peterson.
Okay.
So they came in and, you know, we, we, we, people like a good seven, eight, and deep, you know.
What year was that when they came in?
Because we didn't find them.
They were 65.
But Lloyd was not African American.
We were very, very good on the watch.
Very good on the watch.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
We'll tell you that part of the research I have.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Yeah.
So tell me about that, that reception that you receive, you feel that you receive from the student body in that first year and in the next year.
That you feel?
Well, like I said, you know, I'm oblivious to a lot and I've been a lot of places and, you know, and all of them.
Yeah.
And so, I mean, you sure you got some looks.
And, you know, you know, I just kept going.
You know, I was here to do what I was here to do.
One incident was one of the freshmen players who, I knew, you know, not very well, but, you know, I knew who he was.
He was with his girlfriend and he stopped.
And he introduced me and, you see me in the comments, oh, you're the one in my girlfriend's class.
Yes, okay.
And I said the one what?
And she was totally embarrassed and couldn't even answer.
So I just said, I'll see you guys later.
Right.
But, you know, that was kind of funny, but, you know, you know, you know, but like I said, most of the kids up here had never been.
And they're back people.
So you'll let it all go to school with them or, you know, because I had run into that in the army.
I mean, I was a guy in the army.
He lived mostly southerners who were seen.
They told me they'd seen back from a distance, but, you know, they didn't know, you know.
Wow.
And that was that.
Yeah, they were from the south, living in the middle of small town, Mississippi and places like that.
Right.
And I didn't feel anything in classes.
Classes, street tunes.
Yeah.
Yeah, the professors.
I didn't feel anything.
Teachers or students in the classes.
Yeah.
You know, there was an occasional, yeah, a lot of somebody's car, you know.
I'm okay.
But, yeah.
And finding accommodation in Corvallis and recreation in Corvallis, what was that like for you?
Well, the main thing is when I, the house I moved in to when I came down, it was already active
by African-Americans.
Oh, well, I didn't have a problem with that.
And how did you find that?
To the coach.
I think so.
Okay.
Yeah.
The day were football players.
And one was a non-athlete.
Okay.
Walter Latharich, he's a pharmacist.
The only thing that grew up, we always told everybody he played tennis.
He was about five, four, five, five, and he was a little overweight, you know.
But he's one of my best friends.
He's in Cate, he lived in New York and got in Florida now.
But, yeah, they were there.
And then we moved to another house on something like 17th near the Coliseum.
Okay.
And we never had a ball.
We went over there and the lady, you know.
And the rent was 70 bucks a month.
Then there was four of us, sort of 17, 50 of months.
That's not bad.
I was just a little bit of a little fairness in there.
But yeah, I was nice.
Sure.
I never had any problem finding a place.
Even those only two places.
Well, I lived in an apartment down in the kindergarten over the street.
Okay.
But that, yeah.
I never had any problems with that.
Now, in terms of, you mentioned going to parties because I'm a reason you met up Charlie Brown.
I'm sorry, Charlie White, which is the female in a party.
Did you go to parties that were integrated?
Or did you go to, when you had a social life?
Well, all of the time I was here.
Not one white person had been invited me to a party that I would go to recall.
Okay.
Now, I got invited to people's homes to have a drink or some dinner, you know,
staying like that.
But not ever once, teammates or anyone, never invited me to a party.
But we gave a party every weekend.
Okay.
At your place?
Yes.
So, 9th Street.
9th Street at Go-Go is what we call that.
At the time at Go-Go.
Yeah.
So, all of the, obviously, all of the women at our parties were white.
Okay.
Well, with the exception of two or three, because there were Carol Smith and there was three or four African Americans, women, kind of one.
I lived here in Corvallis.
There's a couple of ones from LA and another from, forget if there's a sacrament over somewhere.
But the majority of the women were white women.
And also, Lloyd Peterson, who's white, he came to one or two of my parties early on.
And everybody knew him.
And nobody, you know, even having the angst, you know, he's from Los Angeles.
So, he had been around black people and playing ball and black so he had no problem with that.
And this Charlie White, I guess he found out we were having a party.
She came to one of our parties and introduced us to authors, he was kiddin' the guy.
But, you know, we talked a lot of time, I forgot, because he was from somewhere in Oregon.
But, yeah, I met her.
And that was pretty much our parties where, like, we gave parties every weekend.
And we would even host other African American American athletes when they came to town.
If they were staying overnight, we'd say, hey, we having a party over here, aren't you guys come over?
Yeah, I mean, everybody's just to go either side, don't sit.
So, they'd come over and we became friendly with all the athletes in the conference,
up and down the coast, because when they came up here, we went to Washington.
You know, they host us, hey, you know, blah, blah, blah.
And then, we had a friend from Seattle who got to school there.
So, when we go up there, you know, she would always have us, you know, over to her place and stuff.
Sure.
And we go to Portland every now and then, so.
Yeah, yeah.
What was the relationship like with the police when you guys had these parties?
Was there any kind of...
I don't know, but I don't know.
Our police ever come into our house.
Yeah, I really don't.
Hi.
Yeah.
I don't remember how that's called.
And what about fraternities?
I mean, that's always been a sore point for a lot of students.
Dealing with fraternities.
I think I got some...
I got a feel from a couple of fraternities who they were.
I don't recall, but I wasn't anything I wanted to do.
Yeah.
On any campus.
Sure.
I'd been in the military.
I knew I lived in barracks and all that stuff with guys.
I had my feel of that.
I didn't want to do anymore of that.
I was just sitting on it.
Yeah.
What I'm getting at though is more of the tension that occurs because fraternity boys...
All this seems to be down on athletes.
Yeah.
You know, I've got the negative way.
You know, things that...
But then, I think I got like, see, I feel now about a couple of people maybe invite to something
and I just kind of...
You said that wasn't interesting.
Okay.
Can you now talk to us a little bit about your going through school then?
So you said your classes really well.
What did you end up as a major in how did you sort of then go on from there?
Well, I majored in business administration with the concentration
in personnel and industrial relations.
And I came here and I started here in September.
I believe of 64.
And I graduated in December of 67.
That's what it's there for us.
And so I left here in 68, 67.
Okay.
I got a job with the company called Crown Zellerback,
which was the largest one of the largest paper manufacturing firms in the West Coast.
And I got that through one of the alumni, a guy who had played here with Paul.
And he worked for Crown Zellerback.
Now, at that time, affirmative action was big.
Really big.
I mean, yeah, any black college graduate could find a job, you know,
and you know, whether you're qualified or not, and I said to say something,
but anyway, I got a job with Crown Zellerback.
And my specific job was to integrate the workforce.
And that was at this company.
Yeah.
And this was in Antioch, California, which was about as a race as you could get.
Really?
Yes.
Antioch is right next to Pittsburgh, California.
Okay.
Now, those two places are all 99.9% of African Americans in that area live in Pittsburgh,
and all the vice living in Antioch.
Well, now I went down there to look for a place to stay.
I'd knock on the door and people would open the door and slam into my face or some wouldn't open the door.
Right.
So I went into Pittsburgh, and I found this apartment house over there, which was not very nice place.
But anyway, I got hard to do that.
And I did a pretty good job.
I was really interested in when I, you know, they wanted African Americans and they wanted more women.
Okay.
Now, this is a manufacturing facility.
Yes.
Now, they had women working already, but of course, the women could only do certain jobs.
Which were working in the factory.
And the factory was packing.
Okay.
You know, they couldn't, you know, they couldn't work in shipping.
Got it.
They had one female lift truck driver, maybe two.
They couldn't operate the machines, which paid the most money.
They couldn't do those jobs.
So they were pretty much there.
A little packing the boxes and that sort of thing.
That's the way it was at that time, it's them also.
So, you know, I would hire people.
I would go out in the neighborhood.
I would go out in Pittsburgh where African Americans were Hispanics.
They didn't have a lot of Spanish working there either.
So I'd go out and I'd get 10 or 12 people to come in.
And at that time, they used to do all this different testing.
The wonderlake, the Minnesota money, the factory, the PMNPI, that took forever.
All of that crap.
Yeah.
You know, and you know, so anyway, we got ready at some point, but I have 12, 15 people in the room taking this test.
You know, and helping them with it because I'm trying to get people in there.
And then I started doing that.
And I'll tell you the people who at that facility, they hated every bit of it.
Now, there were probably 10 or 12 black people working there.
And they had been working there for quite some time.
I mean, they weren't for a few people.
Yeah.
The honestly they had out of black person probably in the last 10 years or so.
But I started filling them up with African Americans, Hispanics, and females.
Right.
And they hated the world.
They stopped as people there.
They hated it.
And I think people out to the department to supervise them.
And the workers were just stared at me.
I got some bad meal in my inbox, you know, about affirmative action.
And one guy was going to put a George Wallace bumper sticker on my car and somebody stopped him.
You know what I mean?
It was bad.
I want to come back though, because I forgot one for you.
Part of your story, you actually got elected as an award here.
It was called the Leadership Award when you got it.
I think it was 65, 66.
Yeah.
The way it voted you was when I got that.
I felt great.
Yeah.
Tell me about what happened.
Oh, what happened?
Well, it probably made me the captain.
Okay.
What was that like?
I didn't, you know, I surprised me.
Okay.
And I didn't feel any angst from the team.
I wasn't a yellow or a screamer anyway.
Not like, go on, just go on with the yellow.
But I would tell guys, you know, and we would have dialogue.
You wouldn't, you know, even give me a stage you did that.
You know, we would, I want to do this.
Why don't you do that?
And when they come down here, let's make sure that we do this.
Sure.
Yeah, that was it.
You know, it wasn't like, I'm this and you got to do it.
Yeah, it was just like that.
We need to stop these guys and this is what we need to do.
And Paul used to always say, excuse me in the huddle,
he'd say this, this, and this.
And then as we broke the huddle, he would always say,
what you got to play the situation.
Because it may not come that way.
So you got to be waiting for it.
And that's what I say, too.
Yeah.
They may not go that way.
They may come this way.
They come this way.
We'll do this.
So, yeah, and I feel good about that.
Yeah, I really did.
Yeah.
And he felt good about it, too.
Paul and I had a real special relationship.
Yeah.
That's making the captain.
But more interesting, you reflect on the student leadership award
that you won.
Was there a leadership award?
No, it was a leadership, I think, was just with the team.
I think Paul's one of the best.
Okay.
Sure.
Let's come back then to your, at the company in Antioch.
So was that your job you continued on with or you said
they were doing?
Well, I did that for a while.
And then I wanted to learn some more about the business.
So I took a production job.
Okay.
And, well, let me go back a little bit.
Yeah, I just, yeah, you go.
When I was bringing these people in to go to work, they had what they call a probationary period.
For these people.
For the new employees.
Which were only 30 days, which is not a lot of time.
But they were terminating these people as fast, almost as fast as I can.
After two, two, three weeks, almost 30 days up and they just said, well, they can't do
the job.
Right.
Now, I said, well, wait a minute, something's wrong.
So, a Hispanic gentleman named Leo Mijadis, I don't remember him.
He and I used to talk and he came to me and said, you know, they're not giving these guys a chance.
Yeah, they're not training them right.
So after 30 days, these people can't do the job.
They're kicking them out.
Right.
So we got to do something.
I said, well, he was a union student also.
So I said, I'll tell you what we're going to do.
We said how we made up a form that had to be filled out every week.
Right.
The supervisor.
What was taught to this just, you know, and this person, male, female, whatever, had to agree.
So at the end of the week, we would sit out with the union steward, myself, and the department supervisor,
not the guy who trained him at department supervisor, and go over that.
And that guy said, nobody told me this, nobody told me that.
Then we could extend this probation period and then we made sure they got the correct training.
Right.
We did that on a weekly basis.
Took all the time, but we did it.
Right.
And we kept starting me and able to retain people because, you know, hiring people, because of my
work, and you sent them for physicals, you spend money, and then they kick them out.
Right.
So we did that.
But then I wanted to expand and so I went out in production, work production, for a while,
shift, work, plus production paid a little more money.
And then I was learning a little more about the business.
And then the safety manager left.
And I decided, you know, I had enough of shift work.
And I decided to go back into the personnel office since I got my pay scale up.
And I went back in as the safety manager.
Now I worked there for eight years, and, you know, doing all this time.
And then I had an opportunity to go with a large construction firm called Lone Star Industries,
which was covered five states, California, Washington, Oregon, Utah, and Hawaii.
Oh, okay.
So you still often get a job?
Yeah.
And I was regional safety manager, which was a big job.
So then I had, you know, to get your car and all that stuff, you get to travel a lot.
So I took that job.
Did you have a family, at that point, or you were still?
Yeah, I had one son.
You had something like that.
I had a son in 1970.
Okay.
And I had a lot of work to do.
Did you ever have any aspirations to be in coach?
Because I mean, after you leave basketball, I mean, a lot of guys kind of me have that aspiration saying,
hey, you know what, I can probably do some of this stuff.
Well, you know, I did a, I told, I told Coach that freshman here a little bit, you know,
and right after I stopped playing.
Okay.
And I guess the reason I didn't stay in coaching, I wanted to get back to California, really.
And so I thought the quickest way for me to get back was to pursue my degree.
But otherwise, I thought about it after, it's not right after, maybe 10 years after.
But I was very disappointed when Paul quit.
1970.
Yeah.
He only had to head coaching down for six, seven years.
Right.
And he just gave it up.
Paul was pretty disappointed.
Did you ever talk to him about why that was?
Because we didn't.
Well, yeah, I don't know that he'd want to.
Okay.
Well, that's okay.
Sure.
All right.
Now, in terms of your connection back to Detroit, it sounds like that got severed a long time ago.
Oh.
Meaning that you never really went, how'd that aspiration go back there?
No, not to live.
No.
You kept your family back there.
Oh, yeah.
In terms of, yeah.
But what happened is, five or six of my nieces and nephews came to California.
Oh.
But only one stayed.
Okay.
They all came, one went to Los Angeles.
They stayed a while, they don't have a one stayed.
They're still in California.
But they all rest on one back to Detroit.
But, yeah, yeah, my family, other than my nephew, here is the, they're all in Detroit.
Okay.
And so you do make regular.
Yeah, I do.
Went back last year, twice.
So this year, just recently, when I was in Las Vegas, my nephew graduated.
So a bunch of them came out.
So we had a nice little family reunion last week.
Yeah.
So I'm going back in August.
One of my nieces is getting married.
So I'm going back for that.
But I'm going to be out of here before a winner.
I know you're feeling good.
Yeah, I went back last September and stayed two weeks.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah.
Carry on the story a little further than you finished working eight years or so you said as in any
other thing.
Yeah.
Then you said you want to do the supervisor position where you were first known.
Regional.
What else did you have to ask that?
Well, I worked that for a while.
And then that company got bought up and they downsized and everything.
So I went to work for a shopping mall.
I was the safety director and large shopping mall.
I've been near San Francisco.
And I worked there for quite a few years.
And then I got into contract security.
I ran the contract security firm in Oakland.
I mean the branch manager there for 12 years.
Okay.
And then just before I was thinking about retiring, I went to work for Bayer.
Bayer come back to us.
Yes.
And I worked for them in Berkeley for two years and then I finally retired.
2004.
Okay.
But then I got bored.
So 2006 rolls around.
I'm at home and I look across the street and I see these kids playing basketball over there.
It was a school for mentally challenged youth.
So I went over there.
Yeah.
They had basketball.
I see what they were doing.
And there were people there were nice.
And they talked me in the driving the school bus.
Yeah.
Because these guys were pretty hard.
They had a lot of female drivers and these guys said they were tough holding the women.
So I did have a three and a half years and I enjoyed it so much.
And then I tried not to escape it.
Yeah.
Now coming back to playing ball, or not just playing ball, but after you left Oregon State
and you ever sort of just played or keep working out or any of those kind of things with ball.
Oh, I played.
Yeah, I played.
They're not the A.U.
But I played for different teams all over the Northern California.
Yeah.
We had quite a, there's quite a, quite a network of teams.
Sacramento, you used to have to march your dime's tournament.
Lake Tahoe had a tournament.
They had a tournament down below Monterey in a little small town called Gonzales, which was a bird.
But it was a real popular tournament.
A lot of extra college players.
You'd see them all the time.
They'd go down there.
You know, somebody would call me in the middle of the week and say, hey, we got a game up in Sacramento.
And I'd jump in my car after work in the Sacramento and I were in half a way.
And I'd go play.
Yeah, I played a whole lot.
I don't remember when I stopped playing organized, but I played a lot.
Right, yeah.
What's the hard nut to play?
I mean, yeah.
I mean, it was just something I did.
Yeah, yeah.
And so, you know, whoever I went, you know, for one of the first things I did was find I'm wearing a guy's play ball.
And I went over there.
And I went to work down and, I mean, even he got out of college, but he had a company team down there.
And he had a lot of large companies around there.
DuPont, Dow, American, US Steel, you know, stuff like that.
They all had teams.
And we played a good league and we played in that league.
And it was good.
We had a lot of fun doing that.
No, you were in Annie.
I can, those teams were mostly integrated.
And we never had any incidents that were playing ball, but, you know, trying to
do something in town initially.
It took a while before they loosened up.
And I got to meet several policemen down there.
And I used to hang out at the cop bar, so.
Oh, okay.
You know.
Yeah, so everything was cool, you know, because some of the, I had hired some of the policemen's kids.
Oh, to be okay.
And to wear our work for the summers, you know, they worked in, oh yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, they worked in, and so, you know, it was pretty good.
Right.
Now looking back on Levy, Oregon State, did you ever have any aspirations going on to play
pressure ball?
Well, I did.
I wanted to play, but I didn't get drafted.
And I didn't want to go take a chance and not make it.
And then I'm not having to any school yet.
Okay.
Now, they had the teams that they have now all over the world.
Yes.
And they got a team, they have teams everywhere.
Yeah, they sure did.
I probably could have gotten jobs away, because my nephew went down and played in Argentina for 13 years.
So, yeah.
So I could have brought, but that wasn't available to us at the time I came out.
And I probably would have jumped at that.
Right.
If I knew that I could go, you know, play for a couple of years in Europe or someplace and make a little money.
You know, could I could come back and finish?
Yeah, yeah, but you really put school to the party, which is a great thing.
Yeah.
Yep.
You thought, is there any questions you want to ask?
At this point, because I think we're sort of at the end of what I had to ask.
Anything that you can think of from the archive perspective that you wanted to ask?
Well, you mentioned Harry Gunner.
So when he came on the team, it was the 65, 66 season.
Was that change the dynamic at all?
Was that nice to have another?
Oh, yeah.
I'm just nice to have him.
Plus, he helped us a lot.
He's the size and strength.
He didn't start, but he played a lot.
Yeah.
He was our sixth man and he was the first guy out of the bitch usually.
And yeah, it's really funny.
Harry and I didn't always room together.
So, you know, because sometimes, lo and I used to room together most of the time.
But you could always find the three of us in one of our bedrooms.
You know, because we were close.
Yeah, I'm right used to hang with us.
Good Lord, didn't loy hated this place.
Oh, he hated every bit of it.
Right.
Coming from Los Angeles, he was one of those players that played, he was a playground player.
Sure.
Because he'd been playing with back kids all his life.
And he was a playground player.
He had more moves.
I'm telling you the canon world, as I say.
And he could play.
Right.
But he and Paul, man, they just didn't.
They never got together for his three years here.
Wow.
Interesting.
And now, he went on to play professional.
Oh, he did.
They played in Chicago over several years, yeah.
And then he finally, now, he married a girl from Madras, Oregon.
Oh, did you know that?
Okay.
But he hated Oregon.
And when he came up here and now, and he hated, he had Paul just never, they never got along.
Never.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, they were glad at each other in practice and on the bench, but, yeah, it was just, yeah.
And it was a hell of a player.
Right.
Yeah.
Now, in the movie glory road, there was actually eventually some tension that occurred between the players.
Mm-hmm.
Just about black and white history.
Black players getting base all the black players taking their jobs.
Sure.
Did you ever get any kind of feeling like that?
No.
We were just so few anyway.
Yeah.
Well, first it was just piece.
I never did it.
I never got any feel.
I've never felt that anywhere.
And I, nobody, definitely ever said it to me right there.
Yeah.
Anything else?
Well, I want to thank you very, very much.
Okay.
It's a great interview and it lasted exactly almost 45 minutes.
Yeah.
Great stuff.
So we really appreciate that.
Okay.
I got to go pick up Paul.
I know he's probably chomping it a bit.
Okay.
Well, I'm pretty sorry about the other one going on with others.
Yeah.
Okay.
Can I give you his back?
Sure.
Give it to me.